good morning everybody
i'm dr henry lee thank you for
uh attending this lecture also i want to
take this opportunity
thank the lab group for their assistant
and
supporting this today we're going to
talk about
brand evidence to testimony to court
in other words the forensic evidence
behind the crime scene to the core
forensic science has a long
history
and if you look at our history
actually start long long time ago
about 700 bc
then later
by 12 country
to 1800 both in asia
and europe star have
documented forensic
science literature
the first traceable one
is a medical legal autopsy book
published in 1248
by the same time in 14th century
to 16th century ensometric was
introduced forensic medicine
um criminology and
criminalistic start introduced to the
field
by 16 to 17th century toxic college
immune knowledge serology was
introduced by 18th century
fingerprint system identification system
was established
in united states the first
laboratory was established
in berkeley by chief
boomer and that laboratory
basically does the identification of
fingerprinting and firearms
then gradually
the forensic science become a major
force
in south domestic you solve the cases
and conduct the investigation
fingerprint is the
area first introduced in the core
1932 fbi established their laboratory
that's all picture in fbi
file as you can see predominantly
is microscopic examination and a
fingerprint identification
firearm identification
um in united states of course
later uh dr
paul kirk wrote the first uh
book called crime investigation
that's the first treaty of a foreign
sick science
forensic laboratory in the past
is pretty primitive of course today
a lot of new advances and a lot of
good scientists join the laboratory
service
in 1988 their survey in u.s
will have 340 laboratory in the country
in 70s we did the survey too only
about 70 some laboratory uh
in the country number 2018
have 412 laboratories
some are fun or lab some are regional
lab
some are stay lab some are conte lab
city lab a private laboratory
those are some commercial laboratory
some are university laboratory
at this moment
approximately eighteen thousand
law enforcement police agency a user
of the laboratory and uh
about 2 300 prosecutors office 3 000
public defender's office utilize
the foreseek service to provider medical
examiner
coroner's office they are about
hundred of those three
between four hundred uh the last survey
is 417. uh 88
are credits
also the forensic few
friends generalized becomes specialized
when i join the field we learn
everything a little bit
but today we have a lot of a suffolk
discipline
such as forensic pathology forensic
odontology
forensic cancer college horosic and
tamales
forensic radiology toxicology psychology
the traditional forensic
identification field we have a
subdiscipline fingerprint
firearm document imprint
trace evidence of course now
if a dna is springing off as a sub
disciplined by syralog
we have chemical uh evidence
computer grant
in addition have so many other
specialized fields anything that just
added that forensic become a foreign
before six days as i say that time
we only have 75 laboratories limited
service
a little public attention not much of a
standard
by year 2002 20
we have more laboratory expanded service
advanced instrumentation accreditation
certification
bus at the same time the laboratory
under public eye
concert security a lot of legal
and scientific issue will have to face
over the year foreign scientists has
gained
unprecedented power over the outcome of
a criminal
and civil cases not long ago
usa today published special
article said 25 hello
that shaped the history of the world
among the 25 news headlines
14 of those forensic scientists would
directly
interact legend for example
iraq war was helping to identify
those shooting reconstruction
kachina we identify
a lot of unknown body o.j simpson
clinton monica case vincent foster case
afghanistan war of course oklahoma city
bombing
caliber massacre that's over there now
all those cases become a
he's involved in forensic evidence
but forensic science
is not like a television or movies
say it's for six scientists
we start from the beginning funding
evidence at the sea
then exam them goes to core
by second commercial reusable finish
analysis by third commercial or already
they linked the suspect
uh the last episode we're eating in a
fancy restaurant
it's not in real life not that way
crime scene is actually controlled by
police
and detective and crime scene
investigator
they're the one collective evidence
where do i
have to preserve and acumen
submit to the laboratory laboratory
scientists we examine the evidence
identify the evidence compare and
individualize the evidence
we submit to the prosecutor's office
or defense lawyer
then introduce to court
so the lawyers control which evidence
you can submit use
the use and the judge is going to
determine
what piece evidence allow
you to testify who
they think accept you
as an expert so if the evidence
not recognized at the scene that peace
evidence
will never become evidence
even though we finish the report
examinable
if the lawyer choose not to introduce
that evidence will never enter the
court if the judge not allow
you all the evidence you will never
testify or not evidence
for example for example dna
it was introduced to united states
by late 80.
as you all know in early 80s
dr alex jeffrey first discovered
a plot a matter
of a foreign identification
once get to u.s corps
prickly was accepted by 1990
almost every core accept that
but just like any other new evidence
after accepted and
of course a lot of objection
um even the first dna scientists test
upon
in florida said dna can be used
but later he rechecked his testimony
said dna had problems so
like any scientific issue what we're
going to do
as foreign scientists usually
forensic view we set up a committee
to uh look at the evidence
try to work out some
procedure the first committee was set up
by
fbi then of course have a
international committee a pandora
national
academy of science set up a
committee we spend a lot of time look at
them
of course like any committee
they need a minority representation
so usually i'm just a token attack all
those
committees uh this is
dr alex jeffrey this person
is dr bodoli the
chief dna scientist from fbi
that's when we're young so many years
later
uh i met alex jeffrey
in india both two of us was your mind as
keynote speaker
look at that time really changed us
he looked at me and said hey
i said alex you look so different now
uh of course dna just like
us when time goes
why a lot of new advances
has been introduced a lot of new yokoma
i introduced to the view i love a new
technique
developed by young scientists
and of course we
even have a rapid dna dna from origin r
uh v i'm tr to amplif
and flip them to str i know
to single nucleotide analysis
most of the nga technique are
standardized now
with standardized kids so many companies
develop so many software you can apply
into our work
in recent days
we probably all read that in a news
article
and uh in california san francisco
uh um a or
case serial killer case
law enforcement credit him for at least
probably eight murder of 80 some victim
was solved by familiar dna
search and forensic genetical genealogy
the differences between these two
really simple the application is the
same
use dna
just
look at the dna we can look at the
family member
relatives and identify the suspect
that's familiar dna search or we look at
a
dna the genetic and trace back
through the genealogy fund
identified the suspect
so in other words we have to have dna
and genetic information a database
look at the dna pattern other
family information pattern
through logistic analysis uh
try to reconstruct
dna of course
just like any other evidence we learned
so much from the history
we saw their evidence
and in recent years
realize the laboratory
with bad evidence and dna
same thing equally through severe
grieving many laboratory
was accused for a
lack of standard lack of a certification
some you have been criticized bring
some scandal around
this all started the year 2009
national academy of science published
booklet strengths
forensic science in the united states
in that box the criticized
with lack of standard especially the
traditional finger
for sick identification field such as
fingerprint
pump ring firearm tool marks
and handwriting even
autopsies of course
dental image
also listed in the
study
then the second white paper was
published
by pcas because
the rapport say forensic view
lack of a standard also the terminology
we use
doesn't meet the scientific
byline and we don't we did not use
statistic
calculation error rate
and the rest of them
so one after another court decision
regards the missing of the physical
evidence
but those criticism
have some merit but
also
it's lack of understanding of the
forensic
utilization application as i say
scene is basically conducted by the
police
or crime scene people or detectives
forensic scientists and the view
actually goes to crunchy
most of them were in the laboratory
so laboratory
gender is important
but doesn't matter what do we examine
what kind of report we issue the
omission of the evidence
to court is not up to us either
is by the lawyer and judge
the miscibility of scientific evidence
involves a lot of issues such as
procedure issue
scientific issue expert issue discovery
admissibility legal standard
legal standard currently in our country
basically we follow fry
or dorba
fry center basically say general
acceptance in the relevant scientific
community
in other words they put the songs
acceptability into the scientists hand
in other words the procedure will use
the methodology everything
it has to be accepted by
the relevant community
the prior rowing actually
started
in 1923 it's nothing to do
with scientific evidence it's about
polygraph that time
because polygraph is not generally
accepted
by the scientific community therefore
the core rule
polyverse cannot be used
as a piece of a legal evidence
normal you basically change the rule
let the judge be the gatekeeper
that makes admissibility
a rule by the judge just to avoid the
factors
whether or not the procedure
was for peer review any
validation and uh any known
of potential error rate and
of course general acceptance
one of the major cases in the united
states
this happened in 1921 because sacco
vendetti case not the emoting
robbery homicide case in massachusetts
[Music]
three people died in this case
psycho and the daddy was later charged
for the crime and executed
now evidence scientific evidence besides
investigative evidence and why witness
evidence
uh the bullet
comparison
that case the comparison was found
in 1921. by 1925
i have a lot of newer knowledge in
regards to
holistic or sapphire arm identification
at the request of the
a committee set up by harbor and
one of the national media asked us to
re-examine
those evidence after we re-examine
the general similarity
after that many years still there
and this two-piece firearm
still there the issue is
which we cannot resolve is this the real
firearm weapon ceased by the police
when their arrest cycle of madei
or is subsequently the two firearm
was used in court
so the bolan strategy
we was able to link to the weapon
but the weapon itself
we don't know the origin so many years
later
in other words the scientists
we only can be responsible for whatever
the portion
we examine currently some of the state
use friar some use
dobro other use a
different federal ruling
called federal 702
in other words the testimony is based
upon sufficient fact or data
the testimony is the product a reliable
principle and matter and the witness
have applied the principle a method
reliable reliability and qualified
to testify if anybody
interested in more detail
a this year
[Music]
north carolina school of law published a
book regards to biological evidence and
law by state
uh it's an excellent references
book system of the
scientific evidence so france signs
to testimony foreign must be prepared
not only to present evidence to court
but also
explain how the evidence gets there
and
what was tested what technique was used
the error ray standard operation
or accept that it's up to the core
so generally those are the issue
we have to understand
as i said before this line
will further separate the three stages
the stage one is by
generally by police
laboratory laboratory scientists
forensic scientists
we examine we identify we compare
we individualize it then we issue our
report
and the evidence goes to court
attorneys they're going to
introduce
the evidence to court and be prosecutor
or defense attorney a mis admissibility
of the testimony
is up to the judge
the biggest area of
this agreement is regards to the patent
evidence
national science foundation and pica
basically
say imprint pattern evidence
cannot be used should not not be used
initially people think just cover
fingerprint
handwriting and those traditional
evidence of course recently they start
questioning blood stem pattern evidence
fabric evidence
and medical examiner
testimony about a womb body condition
voice and a fire scene firebird pattern
tire mark cutting mark machine mark
and a gsr and now
they start giving us questioning about
instrumental
data pattern match and recently even the
fingerprint
pattern uh dna pattern
interpretation
but we have to understand
the pattern evidence consists so many
different kinds
like the scene for example
this summer short ser shirt
involved in a homicide their blood
pattern
i examine the pattern i notice
some recognized pattern rectangle
pattern
like a knife
so that's the knife
police recover
not too far from the scene this is the
night
a homicide night makes that pattern
what the scientists we can do is say
similar
we cannot say positively
identify and here we do dna analysis of
the blood sample
and the analysis of the pattern on the
shirt
if identical
and linked to a victim then we say okay
that's a pattern of individualization
so pattern of identification
this is another homicide case
a triple homicide three people is
murdered
we use chemical tetramethyl benzene
which react with hemoglobin heme
develop a front colorless to a blue
color
we subsequently i cut the carpet
removed from the c this part called
recognition
this part called preservation
identification to the laboratory
we enhance we develop
this label and
the logo the special
design marks subsequently
linked to the shoes that part
called identification identify that's a
shoes
this type of shoes
we did not say that sneaker definitely
made that print until a shoe print
expert
make the comparison look at the general
characteristic
an individual characteristic make such
identification
forensic examination exclusion is easy
for example police submit this
piece of evidence rather they collect
brandon scene
have a sneaker print that's the sneaker
they seize random suspect
of course we don't have to
be a genius say this is an
exclusion but
underneath of this sneaker print there
are some patterns here
is this portion of pattern made by that
portion of this
meter
we don't know that's why
so important we have to
have original evidence we can make a
comparison
yin addition many times
when imprint was made because the
surface just not even
give this piece of paper on a
little floor or on a carpet going to be
have slight differences in size
or you're living in shape
that's why we inherit a
limitation in scientific examination
similarity consistent or matching
for example the signature the
fingerprint
or tool mark or you do a physical match
that's all have different mimi
with the new development in efforts
computerization environment examination
so what is a match you need to one point
or 18 point or six point
what kind of statistic you have to prove
that you can call and match
dna pattern
is this a match or not that match again
subject to a lot of interpretation
pattern evidence besides
individualization
many times it's important for
us to make an interpretation to
reconstruct
for example a victim's body we found
this pattern
i say well a tire
the five rips design
run over this individual for example
this victim
initially they think it's a biomarker
when we examine we say okay this is
not that bar mark it's a pair of
pliers it's a tall mark
so what type of saw used for
dismembering
have its volume although we cannot
provide a
statistical information or error rate
but do have forensic volume
this case demonstrates
the importance of pattern evidence
for example here this picture
shows on interstate i-84 a truck
took the police state trooper police
officer took off
subsequently they set up a roadblock
stop this
vehicle generally hit the wrong case we
look for blur
hair tissue but this case can
detect if they're not bonding able hair
tissue
subsequently they call the police radio
i get to the scene we look at this
pattern
exam with side lighting and enhance
with few chemical fuming we develop
this pattern a
shorter patch of state police
is this a match or is this just a
consistent but doesn't matter
i cannot provide a statistical data
so how many change
a truck will leave this pattern
what's the error rate because i only
have one
case in my career that's probably the
only case
in the world uh i don't think we have
any error rate that says state police
because the pattern
is reversed on the truck the gymban
that's called imprint in that
indentation it's have
tremendous value the suspect later
admitted
and confessed for that case
so many cases pattern evidence
have volume even with a lot of new
scientific development
a lot of new formulas come up
but still it's
up to the attorney to
introduce that piece evidence in core
for example hair
early days here but evidence
generally accepting core as a
identification
by 1992 this case was overturned
but if you just look at the literature a
star
in 1890 i already have article
uh significance of hair in for sick
medicine
in my career i also published quite a
few
papers and a couple of chapters
contribute a couple of chapters and
books
but uh we often call that's a
microscopic similar
when we testify say microscopically
similar consistently but never use
same match
however many laboratories in the country
use the word match
but now all those cases
is throughout the court one after
another
almost three thousand cases
but now with hair examination
start looking at a modern country dna
nuclear dna
root so when time changes
signs changes so forensic scientists
we have to change which the time so just
now
we cover some of those issues
and now we're going to look at that
more critically about
so-called we lack of a scientific method
or general assessments standard
procedure
scientific method basically
is a theory development we start with a
incident
we collect evidence information
we develop hypotheses we'll coordinate
those results
develop alternative verification of the
fact
action decision now you'll have a
hypothesis
after you go through
a paranormal analysis
finally you can eliminate it or
that's not possible uh
then you say you have a theory
you've developed a theory
we follow that
in larger words aiming for a secret
examination
any interpretation that's what we follow
the scientific method
the standard procedure
of course
even in the early days we already
have in 1976 that's the first
new country uh in united states
we have a serology subcommittee
for standardization certification
other than what i put my lecture
almost two thirds of the people
in this picture already no longer with
us anymore in 80s
escola american crime laboratory
directors
association we already have
accreditation
certification uh here
almost i'm probably the only one left
academy forest excise iai
all have their procedure standard but
recently
the national
institute of standard set up a
many subcommittee to
develop this analysis
a lot of good things happen and
future i'm sure going to have a lot of
standardized procedure but
we have to learn from the past
experience
before we do have procedure
but when the evidence goes to court
the lawyers still criticize
so i am not to of domestic say
future without a standard procedure
published
the lawyer would not ask her for his
excitedness anymore
the submission of the physical evidence
is still going to question us regards to
database regards to what we use
the core question the size basically
is lack of supporting data insufficient
experiment what you
sufficient experiment how many
experiments you'll have to do
education training standard
a written procedure that's a standard
so with that in mind
future forensic scientists i think
we still have to face this contamination
issue
degradation of evidence laboratory
conditioning
security procedure whatever the
technique
we use any tech analytic
testing if we do instrument calibration
instrument variability error rate light
code
all those still going to wake us
so testifying core
is a legal issue
justice purdue once said if the law has
made you
a witness remain a man of songs
you'll have no victim to avenge no
guilty millions of persons
to ruin your safe you must bear the
testimony
within the limit of size that's pretty
simple
but unfortunately the scientist
the ethics standard of the individual
some you have a falsify accreditation
qualification some have biases in
conclusion
in interpretation
once the piece about evidence in core
before the testimony we have to
go through that
the lawyer usually opposite side
they're going to discredit themselves
for example if the prosecutor introduced
that piece evidence defense going to
discredit that evidence
if they cannot discredit signs
they usually discredit the scientists
it's a lack of training lack of a
standard lack of procedure and
biases then if they cannot
discredit the scientists they usually
try to figure a way
to demean the scientist try
to create some smokescreen
or even made up some
falsified story
do you even have a workshop how lawyer
cross
exam impeach destroy
expert witness how discredited
truthful expert weaknesses
choose for in other words the expert
tell the truth
how you destroy them they usually start
if we testify for the
prosecution defense
happiness that we are biases
same evidence same testimony if we
introduce
by defense prosecution definitely accuse
us
as a higher gun so it doesn't matter
one way other you're labeled
many events
try to destroy the scientists
found some dirty uh
little history nothing to do with
science
for example or not
you smoke a marijuana cigarette
when you're in college not nothing to do
with dr mullis
is accomplished in dna
his discovery of pcr procedure
samia whether or not have you ever goes
to the new beach
science not always black and white many
times the gray area
for example one time
i was asked to
examine
the individual's pets
whether or not
those evidence consistently
he just murdered his wife
being a result you only can say
that's victims
it's up to the pattern whether or not
this pattern because he said he found
the body
tried to help the victim
or those blue spider
was deposited during the commission of
the crime
so it's the patent evidence which
answers some of the questions
today forensic scientists
we have to be aware of it
from the scene
to the core it's not
like a smooth cell we're squeezed
in between the scientific principle
of fact and the legal and the
admissibility and legal challenge
that's why more and more now they rely
on cell phone
rely on police
body cam rely on cctv camera
even with the reason is a
patient minnesota in my career
i handle about 300 of those police and
mafia shooting case
ferguson is not the first one people
think
miami the first one no before that
so many other cases minnesota are not
going to be the last one
the camcorder captured that
now but the issue
what cause of the best
not subject to again
legal and scientific issue
so numerous area
before we can answer and satisfy
the core that peace evidence
will not become a piece of uh
evidence in court scientific neutrality
is
important but different scientists have
different opinion
that's fine that's healthy but
ideological biases
reason for modification should not be
allowed
for example a case a above
a hamas our case a technician
did some octal under play
that's the early days to determine the
species
that's his work she set up but
lack of a standard lack of a
series of delusion of the gnome
and uh the anti-zero
he used while i evaluate
when i testify i said i cannot tell the
species
that's the acceptable
correct interpretation i
cannot call this is a
human blood or not human blood
because we the standard we're supposed
to set up like this
if you call that's another mobile you
should set up an entire dog
uh fish entire cat whatever anti-animal
serious our panel to determine
what's the uh unknown
the control you should have a serious
solution
with the known anti-serene then you can
correctly make interpretation
i was accused say
i should say this is not human
of course anybody knows any signs
should give the correct interpretation
basically i don't know
which is that kind of a result
you really cannot conclude anything
that's why utilization forensic evidence
we have to be totally objective stay in
the middle
anything associated to suspect will have
to examine
but equally important anything
dissociated suspect
you should and report it down any co-op
in computer evidence you'll have to
report it any excompatory evidence
will also have to report
i'll give you a couple examples for
example this famous
staircase murder become movies
books television shows it's all star
pretty simple
in their home victim's body
was found at the end of the staircase
of course she cannot tell us anything
[__] anymore the only statement
is for the husband say
one of his book was adopted for movie
again
so they opened up a champagne two of
them
drinking celebrate later open up another
bottle of wine
uh she said it's late it's almost
midnight
i want to go sleep tomorrow after work
he doesn't want to waste the y continue
drinking
and here well 2 o'clock in the morning
he walked in from his wife's body
called the police emergency people
arrived
and she's still breathing and
later died on the road
initially medical examiners think that's
an accident
because every year of about 13 000
people in this country out of a
staircase accident
but the police investigator
who is a uh forensic scientist
look at this pattern uh he reached a
conclusion
this is a homicide beating
those plus there is bleeding
medical examiner re-examine
the body the chief medical examiner
conclude
say that's a hamsa
the forensic scientist testified he had
a
extensive experience and he recognized
that
[Music]
she was killed by
a fire poker
i testify when i look at that
the pattern at the sea the staircase we
found hair with
potential fingerprinting here looks like
she was
standing up and coming down trying to
get up again
cause a lot of blood smear uh
here predominated blood it's
not because beating with a
fire poker because fire poker usually
have to
leave a cast off pattern and then we
should pop
on the ceiling on the upper portion of
the wall
not in the bottom yinger fishing
we look at those pattern and uh looked
at the autopsy
uh she has a uh
0.07 percent by alcohol
and ying edition
she uh taxing colleges on
uh thousand peng in uh
his autopsy uh her autopsy sample
when we look at this pattern you can see
it's not consistent with whole blur
because no center those are whole blue
and now the rest of majority it's not
not only just so many
no center this type of bluster
generally produced by coffee
because that air bubbles voice double
once deposit on the surface the
blood dry the air bubble bust so you
leave say holy
pattern or we call ghost
blue skin and some of those
smear which is tells us
the sequence of your back some of the
pattern
underneath of that smear some on top of
the smear
which means she was lying there
suffering
husband was outside drinking did not
even know
she fought on the stair how to prove
that
really difficult to prove that what kind
of experiment
the only thing we can think about is use
some blur put in the mouse
and cough up let the jury see the
pattern
but uh this was criticized
and of course the truth
and justice pretty difficult
there are many techniques that used by
lawyer
how to trust the fact how to mislead the
car
all those issues and
my testimony basically
consistent with the accident
let's go grill a couple days on that
why we don't do saliva test i said
that's the prosecution's job
to do the salava test i got to the scene
so late
and the evidence is not original
anymore of course
they are few prosecution witness
just to say that's for you
but anyway jewelry fund is guilty
he was convicted to serve
life
in jail after he was convicted
a pendant swim sympathize to his side
now
so many radio talk shows so many books
so many television show
and one after another and the young
adishi
they start look at the
euro investigation the this guinderson
project
did their excellent job somebody else
confessed to the crime
they found original evidence
was falsified by the same expert
testified in this case and
of course the
colorado
bureau investigation attorney general or
under fire and
they set up a special panel
to review all the cases from a lot of
problems
which the case from his given his
qualifications
uh was forgery and of course
peterson case he said he did the
experiment
and uh they found the file
extremely really uh
all those usual
um
[Music]
he did not even use fire broker he just
use a 2x4
ship some of the mannequins have
and create a little bit splatter uh
he said he conducted experiment um
this file videotaping doing that and
of course the rest of this history uh
attorney general resign laboratory the
people get fired he was arrested
now he served galter
and peterson was out
and
the case was resolved of course with
recent this events in the talking
because the pandemic how common
social distance three feet six feet
why because why i have to wear a mask
because each time you call you create
thousands of splatter come out
most are not visible those are deposited
on the surface that's why we'll have to
wear a mask
that you can use high-speed camera
capture
those patterns now everybody say
dr lee you are correct the
interpretation
uh it's constantly important
uh with today the fake news
the public really don't know what
happened now
somehow another
news are false apart a lot uh
brainwashed the
uh public
for example the next case i want to
present
is a uh spectre
um recently spectre died
in the jail january 16 2021
died of a covert 19 infaction
it started pretty simple because the
time we're going to
go quick on this uh he was
so famous in 70s 80s
lived in this mansion but february 2nd
that night
somehow something happened he went to
house of blue a bar in hollywood
beverly hills subsequently by the
morning
of a february 3rd police was called
to his machine for landing correct's
body there
i'm going to skip all the fact if you're
interested
um you can contact me
and recently i just gave a talk
uh we also had a workshop just on this
michael peterson factor case
at our university spring
homicide conference
mega monster ratio when we examine the
photo we found
she had a chip on the fingernail
this is a fake fingernail
underneath is her original
fingernail with a little chip
is the fake fingernail
somehow during the trial that become
important
the prosecution with the witness
former la detective
he said he saw me took a fingernail
at the scene from the fingernail
and when he asked he even give the size
a whole fingernail and red
in color when the cross
he re-emphasizes it's a real
red fingernail defense attorney asked
him
how he knows that he said
ah did you use magnaflow glass he said
my eyeglass
it's a magnafocus he's far away
from that area he can see it
how's that kind of a scientific evidence
is this a legitimate scientific evidence
and of course you be the
person to judge then my second witness
said dr lee did not take a fingernail dr
bob took a tooth why
twos and a third
individual they put on
did not take anything dr lee took
something
size like a fingernail now
you have got three different sort of say
why material size like a fingernail
white twos or red fingernail
guess what the news report say judge
said defense with all the evidence
i took a fingernail
in other words weakness
testimony
three different one how the core can
rule that how the newspaper
can report that the chinese
newspaper even worse say i'm under
arrest
for destroy evidence
but the bottom line that piece whatever
i collect
is some fabric already on october
10 2006 fedex
to los angeles laboratory
they signed a receipt
so it's difficult this topic
to cover in one hour
i hope i got the point across
and front the scene to the call
random evidence become testimony we have
to throw
a lot of rigors
across examination and uh
again it's kind of a
history repeat and uh
of course that period of the time a lot
of uh
i want to thank take this opportunity a
lot of scientists
come out supporting me and a lot of
people are writing
a letter to editor try to correct that
a lot of newspapers really cover
the television correct correctly
fact after they fought now and
after my news conference those evidence
already long
sent to the police
so of course those
controversial stop recently
uh i just learned the district attorney
lost the election if the public don't
trust
the office definitely you're going to
lost your luck
young addition california judge rule
a prosecutor and police engage massive
misconduct
and now a lot of cases reverse
subject to review therefore
it's so important each of us doesn't
matter your scientist or lawyer
or news reporter we all have to follow
same principle standard scientific
legal procedure technical ethic
whatever we do you cannot
lower your standard once again
thank you very much as a forensic
scientist
we have to have knowledge
in our mind have courage
in our body
when you go to car when you go to sea
middle of the night
when victims family call you or suspect
family call you
you have to have the honesty to tell
them the truth
uh have friend in your life again i want
to thank la rude and
so many scientists and lawyers
you're my friend thank you so much